[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a canadian superhero comedy
film called turbo kid spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
in an alternate 1997 a post-apocalyptic
society lives in a land nicknamed the
wasteland that is littered with trash
the scarcity of water has turned it into
a form of currency this society is ruled
by a sadistic and tyrannical overlord
named zeus who lives in a place called
the hell house in the opening scene a
man named scout stands in front of zeus
and a cheering crowd of his followers
the leader likes to organize fights
between the people he abducts from the
city they battle to the death inside of
a dried-up swimming pool zeus owns a
contraption that is designed to extract
water from the human body everyone who
dies in the fight is sent into the
machine where their body is shredded and
mushed to extract 10 gallons of water
currently the crowd is chanting scout's
name because he has killed all the
opponents he was made to go against
however zeus cannot let a brave man like
scout get away freely he makes his
savage right-hand man skeleton kill him
with a hammer to his head somewhere else
a teenager known as the kid lives alone
in a bunker to survive he scavenges
through the wastelands looking for
valuable things of the past but the task
is not so easy the crisis has caused
people to turn into blood-hungry animals
ready to kill anyone for a drop of water
the kid must remain hidden and away from
the dangerous people to remain safe one
afternoon he cycles to his work at a new
garbage dump the place is foreign to him
so he is extra careful while looking
through the trash he comes across three
decapitated heads mounted on sticks this
means someone has marked the trash as
his own and is warning foreigners to
stay away the kid marks the place in his
notebook that he uses to keep track of
safe areas he then takes off before
being caught after cycling for a while
he reaches his home an underground
bunker inside the bunker are all of his
belongings that he has found at the
dumping site it is not the safest place
in the town for someone like him but the
kid is fortunate enough that he has
never been attacked a while later he
makes his way to the local pub where
only the regulars are allowed to visit
the place is inhabited by a water trader
named baggoo the kid usually exchanges
this stuff he finds with the trader for
food and water this time he gives bagu a
pen for a single bottle of water the kid
is sad because it is not enough for him
to survive a week baghu notices this and
gives him a turbo rider comic the kid's
face lights up in joy since he is a
die-hard turbo rider fan then we are
introduced to a professional arm
wrestling cowboy named fred he is also
at the pub challenging a huge man after
an intense match of arm wrestling fred
wins as usual and the opponent has to
treat the entire pub to drinks just then
one of fred's associates comes to him
with shocking news fred's brother scout
has gone missing at the same time the
kid is in a playground reading the comic
suddenly a girl appears beside him and
talks to him like they're friends the
kid panics and tries walking away but
she stops him and makes him wear a
strange wristband she then starts
talking to a corpse which makes the kid
run away somewhere else we see fred and
his men walking to the hell house to
look for scout unaware that he is
already dead they stop to take a rest
when skeleton attacks and brutally kills
most of them fred is left alive and
brought to zeus in the bunker the kid
wakes up to find the girl from the
playground looking at him she introduces
herself as apple and aggressively tries
making friends with him even though the
kid is not interested it turns out that
she followed him using the wrist device
the kid had dropped the comic book in
the playground which she returns in turn
he allows her to stay with him for a few
days he takes her out to scavenge and
teaches her the ways to survive in the
wasteland the more they stay together
the more he starts liking her
personality fred is brought to zeus's
place as a hostage zeus has heard of him
as the famous arm wrestler to test his
skills he asks him to show his moves
against skeleton fred pretends to extend
his hand but then attacks them when he
tries to punch zeus skeleton cuts his
hand off meanwhile the kid and apple get
along pretty well when asked about her
family apple says that her former best
friend died and left her alone the kid
was the first person she met after that
hence she immediately made him her best
friend the two play tag which reminds
kid of the childhood he never got to
enjoy
suddenly a man emerges from the bushes
and abducts apple the kid runs away in
fear but the man follows him at one
point he falls off his bicycle and ends
up on top of a door to a bunker it
breaks making him land inside the place
is unlike anything he has ever seen it
has a strange glowing sphere that the
kid touches in fascination as soon as he
does so the bunker lights up he
carefully makes his way forward and
finds the corpse of his favorite
superhero turbo rider sitting in front
of the control panel it turns out that
he was supposed to save humanity from
destroying the earth but was killed
before he could complete the mission the
kid wears the superhero gear and
discovers that it still works he can
throw powerful electricity through his
hand that kills with a single shot the
kid has now turned into his favorite
superhero and is ready to save his
friend he goes on a search for apple and
comes face to face with the man who
abducted her the man uses his detachable
punch to attack the kid but his attack
is weak against the turbo's powerful
jolt of electricity in the hell house
fred apple and a stranger are positioned
inside the empty swimming pool they will
have to fight zeus's men and the ones
who lose will be juiced for water before
the battle starts the kid arrives and
claims that he is a superhero zeus
laughs asking him to showcase his powers
but the kid's wrist device runs out of
power and stops working he is also
thrown into the pool with the others and
the fight starts initially apple starts
beating the enemy and the others watch
in awe before joining the pool turns
into a puddle of blood but the kid and
the team win in the end zeus is
surprised by the results but he goes
against his words and attacks the group
apple is shot dead while the others are
attacked from behind suddenly the kid's
armor recharges itself and he manages to
defeat everyone with his powers the
group walks away leaving a stunned zeus
behind as soon as they are out of sight
he orders skeleton to kill all of them
in the following scene apple and the kid
are on a couch somewhere in the fields
the kid notices a hole in apple's chest
and discovers she is a robot initially
he freaks out and retreats but apple
acts like her normal self which brings
him back she also reveals that she is a
friendship robot made to become people's
emotional support while returning home
she lags for a few seconds when she
recovers she finds out that her
transmitter is damaged and will only
work for a few more days to find a new
one they meet baghu the water trader he
knows of a place where many useless
robots are dumped that might still have
a working transmitter the duo makes
their way to the dumping site but apple
stops working abruptly slowing both of
them down they stop for the night and
take a rest behind the remains of a
building the kid tells apple about his
parents who were killed by zeus when he
was young at the same time skeleton and
his people have found baghu and abducted
him with his guts attached to the wheels
of a bicycle he is asked about the kid
he tells him that they went to a robot
dumping site but skeleton kills him
anyway the following morning skeleton
arrives where the kid and apple are they
run away but are eventually cornered on
a cliff skeleton uses a sharp disc to
decapitate apple a shocked kid tries to
catch her head but falls off the cliff
in the process skeleton thinks the enemy
is dead and returns to the hell house
what he doesn't know is that the kid
survived with no injuries because of his
armor they finally reached the robot
dumping site but now apple doesn't only
miss a transmitter but the entire part
of herself below her head the kid tapes
her head to a random body urging her to
wake up but it never happens a flashback
shows us that zeus was just a scavenger
before he killed the kid's parents and
robbed them when the kid wakes up he
finds himself with fred the man is
taking him to a safer place but has left
apple back at the dumping site because
she is a lost cause suddenly skeleton
appears in front of them yet again as
the two get ready to fight we see apple
coming back to life she uses the wrist
device to look for her friend back in
the streets zeus joins his right-hand
man and mocks the opponent for trying to
fight them a group of his people attacks
the two and a battle ensues since he
last fell off the cliff the kid's armor
has stopped working leaving him with
only his raw strength to fight the
opponents the place turns into a
bloodbath as the people use gruesome
ways to kill each other even fred
manages to break skeleton's hand leaving
him defenseless the kid does his best
and kills most of them but struggles to
overpower a girl right then apple
arrives on her bike and stabs the enemy
with the unicorn horn she reunites with
the kid and gives him a spare part for
his armor that will repair it still zeus
refuses to give up he shoots the kid and
apple declaring his victory forgetting
that the kid is protected by his armor
and apple is not a human the kid
launches a final attack on him and kills
the villain in the end he and apple kiss
under the reign of blood but then a
twist shocks them zeus stands up again
revealing that he is actually a robot
which means the attack did him no harm
he is a corporate model designed to be a
human's friend but he was treated
ruthlessly by them hence he killed his
master and over the years created his
kingdom to rule over humans the kid
calls him a mistake and blows him up by
shooting explosives that frederick
brought along with them but the last
explosion harms them as well apple saves
the kid from it but dies in the process
the kid holds her in his arms mourning
her death in the following scene the kid
buries apple fred reveals that the
explosion earlier caused a stream of
water to emerge from the ground he wants
to deliver it to the people of the
wasteland and save hundreds of lives the
kid wishes him luck and rides off to
explore the other side of the wastelands
where he has never been before
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching